this is the technical difficulties were
playing citation needed joining me today
who reads books you know it's Chris Joel
everybody's favorite Gary Brown Gary
Brannen yes I did order a crunch corner
but not that crunchy
I'm the bounty smell this my brain is he
Lizzy
let's get busy bang bang bang oh in
front of me I'm asking Wikipedia in
these folks can't see them fighting at
Ryan's point and a ding and a special
prize for particularly good answers
which is and today we are talking about
camp Bonifas is that like a smiley gaunt
Alamo count Bob on Polyface farm road I
mean I'm getting this point because it's
a United Nations command military post
so it's not the US but it is it is camp
in the sense of military posts so I will
give you the set camp in what all the
sense in the sense of a place you go to
camp with a tank you mean forget his
pants I can't sleep given the bone is
actually polari that is actually all
that wrong yeah Paulie being the
language of gay men in the night yeah
fifties and sixties descended from
carnival speak so you know if you hear
Kenneth Williams Jimmy man sandy you
know bevarly Orry quite a nice face
stuff like that is how gay men would
talk to each other so that the police
and other people couldn't hear them so
as the problem sexuality was entirely
illegal and it's a star a sonocent put a
lot that's Polaris something else log
deploy he has made it into regular
English um look um Barney having Hannah
Barney I'm someone is in there well us
we got ownership shushing baggage is to
do your pair and have a handbag or
something yeah uh Natalie now as well as
narrable yeah basically as with so many
things the rest of Britain just went
without so bring this all back camp
Bonnie face do you ll does does not I
it's Boniface does not mean just someone
with a nice pace yeah why is it you know
when you say United Nations command
center I am merely think damn that's
exciting
it'll just be lots of us because you
grew up on
Anderson and Thunderbirds or anything
gets new examination no command center
no I saw some dull men looking at
laptops just for the laptops in a hotel
room
yeah well not in a hotel room here
definitely on the hook it's an actual is
a little Kent is an actual camp in the
sense of military encampment Europe oh
definitely not America also a Middle
East
no you're all wrong vanishes United
Nations look Antarctic so not something
Spanish no you've listed most of the
regions of the world I think I think
you've missed three continents Africa
Australia Thompson's remaining ones
haunt over there we go literally the
last continent to be named it's not
because we didn't like you who were just
saving you for last like that's that's a
terrible chatter plopping down work for
me oh you're on the cutting room floor
now very flex works on me so where is
there going to be a United Nations
command post in Asia is it Korea
yes you're absolutely right I'm gonna
ask a loaded question here so I have a
point which one the bottom one can I say
an either Gary gets the point that it's
on the border yes it is what it it was
it's now it's now become various other
things but yes this was the United
Nations command military post 400 meters
south of the southern boundary of the
Korean DMZ right because that's the only
have North Korean soldiers at one side
of a room staring at South Korean
soldiers on the other side of the room
and they never communicate never the
publishing that person if I go 8-8 and
holding the other tube essentially yes
that was part of their job um it was
returned to being Korean territory in
2006 but yes this was from many many
years the home to the battalion who rose
all the Armistice Agreement hmm um so
what can you find there what could you
find that party captain doesn't it it
was just it was like school classrooms
that were effectively that that was the
channel you were go through for whatever
the immigration laws yeah I'll give you
a point small collection of buildings
surrounded by triple coils of razor wire
oh that's not good I would it would look
like like a big Boy Scout camp if it
wasn't for girls of all surgeons guns
all the Korean men with guns the biddin
bap all the land mines point if it if it
wasn't for for the land mines that
surrounding this can I just point out
it's not being on a Yorkshire Scout camp
were you scalped cells as girls I was in
beavers a club I was a scout oh I was in
the send jobs ambulance as well yeah I
did most of the full thing apart from
becoming adventures do you know yourself
is that how you got in the ambulance no
doubt my my Scout trip has so few Scouts
in it after spending weeks where we
built an Airfix kit shell the crab
Hillary yeah it was a like all alike
john crab a shine we built at a small
balloon as well one night out of tissue
paper with a little basket and any for
paraffin that raised the roof and they
saw fire and that's how i learned how to
use a co2 fire extinguisher you got a
useful skill i think i learned more
about than time not something honest
with you and then one night we try
cooking on it on a cooker a little
paraffin cookers i just leaked
everywhere and set the place on fire
again
I shut down shortly afterwards what can
I say
a you were a scout what I was a scout
your house which you want a proper scare
house yeah we used to go and build like
zip lines in the woods and go yeah maybe
so but did you ever win this count
Eurovision no thank God we never entered
basic adorable kids singing adorable
songs in our costumes I did you had a
very different scouting yeah well like
we went scouting instead yeah we didn't
see you but you do things with wood and
water doesn't mountains and maxes and
fires I sang the solo in my mummy is one
in a million I seem to be fair by the
time I actually got to scout to the
first two years we spent fighting yeah
there's really two hours a week go down
have a rumble then eventually we change
later we did do some we'd do that
where you fill a boxing glove with sand
tied to a rope and spin it round you got
to jump over it then give that one the
perjur'd you ever play barrels
I doubt which was barrels barrels is 3
walk barrels in the middle of the room
of full if you're feeling particularly
the addictive then the whole troupe
joins together in a circle gives you arm
which one that one why like that yeah
and then you run in a circle Oh God and
if you let go or if you hit the barrels
you're out naturally this eventually
leads to some of the 11 year olds being
put between two 16 year olds and smashed
into the batter of wood although I saw
the boxing glove one Irish room but now
one week we didn't replace the boxing
glove with an axe
nice that's more your level of scale
Omega Point South Yorkshire Scouts West
you'll just go whereas I had a Commodore
64 yeah I did not do round are you gonna
say you're in the day as I was in the
movies was I had a Commodore uh so yes
are you talking through parts camp
Bonnie fast yeah which which would look
like a big boy scout a lot like self
your eyes yeah minefields and - oh yeah
did you stop a load of old ammunition -
yeah it's one of them sold ammunition in
bus so there was one other thing you'd
find there the kind of thing you would
find if you had aa say at some board
commanders who are all used to doing a
certain thing with each other
pornography no a steam room oh
definitely not
battleship the ball game it's certainly
a game actual battleships oh not in the
DMZ solo the everybo the cyber gulf
point ah what was called the most
dangerous hole engulf a three-part one
hole golf course for it's got an
astroturf green and landmine and
surrounds 30 so it's my microphone tips
well again nobody guns in this without
again it there's the map good luck
um allegedly a one tea shop did actually
set up a landline oh really it's it's in
the rough yeah you would actually enjoy
that one yeah that'd be such a great
stress
he shot it's got a bit and let it's got
a bit of distance on it it's fine if
you're if you're like what three paths
as a good job there for a start yeah
that lad mind going up in the distance a
look brilliant did get a log all flat
from the distance oh no that's
definitely not what happened at one
point because the name of camp Boniface
it was it was originally camp Kittyhawk
what happened or I mean the name of it
clan gives it away this is the ax murder
incident
now obviously land I'm not giving you a
point for successfully guessing there's
an axe murder what happened in the DMZ
did someone wander into the DMZ by
accident or not by accident no on
purpose you wouldn't need the axes would
you because you don't got lung violence
for that business did the person that
was wandering have the axe uh they had a
max why'd you go into the DMZ with an
axe so the tree down point I'm sorry
right some of the sudden in the Bell now
yeah oh I can't think why but it is so
some folks in the southern side went in
uh to cut down a poplar tree that was
blocking the UN observers if the North
Koreans promptly arrived with axes of
their own and the tree was not being
chopped down anymore and one of the
people killed was called Boniface that's
where the name of the camp came from
three days later American South Korean
forces they launched operation to cut
down the tree with a show of force what
do they call that operation May thaw
legendary American who cut down trees
washing no oh that's chopping down
cherry trees person with a stupid hat
Davy Crockett oh he planted trees and
that was Johnny Appleseed oh yeah
remember everything truly an American
and yeah Americans in the comments will
be screaming at you at this point we
don't know we're not from this giant
lumberjack American folklore Paul Bunyan
never know never heard of it never heard
those words with work Wow okay I've
heard the word Paul I've heard the word
Bunyan but every time you
yeah yeah okay Americans we don't know
about Paul Bunyan in the same way you
don't know about Michael Barrymore all
right us that's not really the same way
I'll be honest different order of
magnitudes and different order more finn
mccool oh yes I'm jealous all laughing
McCrory yes I should have to read yeah
my science of light entertainment though
what finn mccool yeah Saturday night is
hearing up on the rocks tonight so what
is what is on the DMZ now I married with
a hole in the bottom of it the tree is
gone where the tree is gone Oh at least
they've they won the club oh yeah they
did North Korea accepted that yes yeah
okay yes we probably shouldn't have done
that
and yet was a yes you've just sent in a
lot of soldiers to chop down that tree
having okay yes have the tree have
several and what a plaque or something
like that
tourists point that's a bit you can go
and visit isn't it oh you're actually
going a bit further now yeah if you
actually get permission to go and you
can get to the crossing point you can
technically enter North Korea briefly
they there are even tall companies that
do things but you have to pay a naughty
government some money yes it is possible
to get the DMZ if you're a tourist with
a lot of permissions a lot of papers
sign now which is closer than then Camp
one of us ever was the camp itself has
been handed back to Korea but they have
the Korean version of Buckingham palace
guards yes they do yeah just two men
standing there that what one of whom is
fine with you being here the other one
who deletes the photos off your camera
one tell for true how someone shoot
people ask open questions why don't more
bothers work like that and the ones of
the truth in their lies because
everybody's seen labyrinth but I was
everybody knows the answer yeah but
that's fine us a lovely system to filter
who comes in of your country if you've
seen David Bowie's bold you're allowed
it on you
what's happened I'm gonna say this you
deserve that
if you've suffered by the time I just go
with the zoom function of my DVD player
where my wife was out of the room so I'm
the loop feature as well when she came
back in the zoomed in looped version of
David birth the light David Bowie's Kaka
balls dance mellow but just just the
crotch well no this is this is the seal
and he has not got a lump on there's a
point where they got him the codpiece
and there are scenes they shot
beforehand where they went oh boy they
see that whole lot that you know it's
like a party around this ice it's like
it's like several puppies in a paper bag
so it's it's doing the magic dance
sequence where he's dancing from side to
side I'm gonna dance melt it dance that
bit that's the bit he doesn't have the
crotch you later on the fragile lids are
worse Jim Machine and brought you now
thread you later it's it's like a
helicopter sideways on its that's a
flying Gary at the end of the show
congratulations Gary you know uh
conversations you in a circular muscle
with the head of a man and the body of a
lion
oh is this Sphinx tur no hero ever
well with that we say Thank You Christy
always we're just the muscle got
extremely uh gods to my brain clenching
Ivan Tom Scott we'll see you next time
cooking why is the lion walking like
that